36 receivers drafted between thursday
friday and saturday that's tied for the
most in a seven round draft 13 in the
first two rounds so if we are looking
for rookies to make a contribution right
away
it may be a receiver who makes our draft
today's draft the pick with the most
immediate impact in the nfl i've got the
trivia question for christopher if he
gets it right he gets the first pick
chris last year three rookies made the
pro bowl nick bosa was one
name one of the other two rookies who
made the pro bowl offense defense
special teams
oh my gosh i'm totally gonna choke to
death here oh man offense defense or
special teams i know special teams
you're saying something there that must
there must be somebody special teams who
am i missing
oh my gosh i'm choking under the
pressure i don't know go ahead i'm
totally choking
womp
only your second most embarrassing
moment of the day unfortunately uh
the answers are mikol hardman of the
chiefs and deontay harris of the saints
they both made it as special teamers i
thought that hint would help but again
it's not easy to do when the clock is
ticking all right the clock is ticking
on me and this one is easy for me the
last player taken in round one clyde
edwards hillaire who undoubtedly will be
the starting running back sooner rather
than later for the kansas city chiefs
and he will have opportunities to run
the ball he will have opportunities to
catch the ball he will be playing with
patrick mahomes and company so we will
notice clyde edwards hillaire more than
we will notice any other rookie he will
make the most immediate impact in 2020
chris
yeah i mean i don't disagree he was
certainly on my list i got seven names
here and he certainly was one of them i
don't know
uh it's gonna be big time i mean i know
you and i we were we were excited about
the possibility of him playing in that
offense and it's kind of like
you know i don't want to say it but it's
almost like golden state getting kevin
durant where you're just like whoa how
the hell are you gonna stop this team
now with this this amount of weapons so
awesome pick by them uh i'm going to say
on the offensive side of the ball i'm
going to go with cd lamb and the dallas
cowboys one i mean i think he's the most
talented receiver in the draft but two
because of the support system and the
town around him i just think he's gonna
really benefit from that his rookie year
you know allah juju smith schuster when
antonio brown was there and ben
roethlisberger and i you know and again
i think cd lamb is a more talented
football player than a juju smith
schuster but with amari cooper the
running game that they have and of
course not a bad cast of characters at
the wide receiver position in a tight
end position to go along with it i just
think cd lamb in this new offense with
mike mccarthy's ideas and i know they
still got uh you know
kellen moore there
i just have a hard time thinking he's
not going to find a real niche for
himself and see some very beneficial
matchups because of the other guys
around him
somebody asked me for the mailbag column
that we do every sunday to
rank how i believe henry ruggs 12th
overall to the raiders jerry judy 15th
of the broncos and cdlam 17th to the
cowboys will perform at the nfl level
and i put lamb first because of the
things you just mentioned you put any of
those guys in that spot where amari
cooper is going to draw double teams
you've got ezekiel elliott to soften up
the front seven to make the passing game
more effective generally and you've got
dak prescott you're putting that
receiver whoever it is rugs or judy or
cd lamb or anyone else in a great great
spot and i flip it around a guy like
henry ruggs and i'm not picking henry
ruggs because he doesn't have a number
one receiver who's going to be double
teamed i think derek carr is bumping up
against the ceiling he's never going to
bust through and i think the support
staff around a henry ruggs isn't nearly
as good as it is in dallas or even as
good as it is for judy in denver so i
agree with you on cd lam all right the
next one for me and and this one's
simple because to have an impact you
have to be on the field and of all the
quarterbacks taken to the draft there's
only one guy we can look at with any
degree of confidence to say this guy's
going to be on the field from week one
barring an injury and that's joe burrow
the first overall pick in the draft and
i think he's going to be very good at
the nfl level based on what i have
gleaned so far based on what guys like
you have said based on what others have
said based on what we saw at lsu last
year right and uh you know the bengals
have saw they have a a great stash of
weapons there but i think when you have
improved quarterback play that's going
to make some of your guys look even
better you give him joe mixon you give
him aj green they need to worry about
the offensive line but i think burrow is
going to have a big impact right away in
part because he's going to be out there
from the moment the season begins
no doubt about it and he just you know
everything that we've seen like you said
just watching college football the way
he handles himself i mean he's going to
have a huge impact on that team the city
everything about it and then to draft a
wide receiver like t higgins to start
the second round to go along with it to
help that investment you know as we know
they're going to have joe you know uh
their their left tackle what's his last
name from last year jonah i'm biking on
his name from alabama he'll be back
healthy and like you said there's some
pretty good weapons there so i
understand that uh i know i almost made
him the first pick but he's been the
first pick so i didn't want to make him
the first pick of this draft too i just
wanted to change it up a little bit uh
this draft entails slightly less
compensation for the first pick
a little less a little less i don't
think you're going to be paying them
that kind of money all right my next one
i'm going to go to your squad i'm going
to justin jefferson the minnesota
vikings you know again there's there's a
lot of things to like about justin
jefferson the player first off i can't
get over that he was still on the board
for your minnesota vikings at pick 22
you know has it all but when you look at
the receiving room right now for the
minnesota vikings who are you looking at
you know adam feeling what tajay sharp
right you guys signed him you know bibi
is a guy so this is
sure
uh yeah well he's definitely jefferson's
going to be
the second receiver and him and adam
thielen size over the middle we know
they want to play two backs one tight
end two receivers you know so to go the
play action pass the run game everything
off of that justin jefferson's really
going to benefit from it so i look at
him as having a big statistical year
being a big part of that offense
see and i didn't even have him on my
list because the vikings have not had a
good history of first-round receivers
ever since troy williamson now percy
harvin was good in 2009 uh until the
wheels kind of came off for him in
minnesota but i i think that they're
better off finding their receivers late
in the draft or not at all like stefan
diggs round five or four adam thielen
undrafted i worry about justin jefferson
just because of the that expectation
that extra expectation like you're
talking about he's going to come in as
the number two guy he's going to come in
as a guy who's expected to do a lot to
justify the draft position that could
make it even more challenging all right
i was going to be
um kind of a wise acre here and pick
jordan love because he's already made an
impact on the packers not the kind of
impact that we are talking about in this
draft but the mere fact that they picked
him has caused uh packers nation to turn
upside down i'm going to go instead with
derrick brown the seventh overall pick
to the carolina good pick to the extent
to the extent that the elias sports
bureau does adopt your f up the play
stat derrick brown will lead all rookies
in that category and you know as you
were saying the other day this is like a
warren sapp type of a guy a guy who can
come in and be very disruptive he's been
compared to chris jenkins who was a
mainstay in carolina for years just that
interior force that can screw up a play
to the point where the rest of the guys
can get the job done that's what ground
can be for the carolina panthers a guy
that that has very little sex appeal in
his game because he doesn't carry the
football or catch the football or throw
the football but he's going to be a guy
who keeps the other team from doing any
of those things whenever they face the
panthers that's right i mean it's these
type of guys that you need on your team
to win championships i mean that that's
ultimately what we're talking about here
you know whether it's warren sapp or
deforest buckner or whatever it is you
know yeah we don't talk about these guys
aaron donald we don't talk about these
guys a lot yes they don't have sex
appeal but more times than not when you
look at the teams in the super bowl they
have those type of guys like deforest
buckner eric armstead chris jones who
made a number of plays derek brown yeah
he reminds me of warren sapp but he's
like the size of chris jenkins which was
like a true nose tackle and 33 30 pounds
you know this gets kids phenomenal mike
and yeah the f up the playstat
disruption whatever you want him to do
he can do it and i think him paired
along with kawan short and what the
carolina panthers did in the draft was
just i i think they blew it out of the
water they killed it and this started it
off right here with this greek talent
derek brown it was really probably a top
five pick and uh great for them to have
him on the board at number seven all
right good pick there you stole mine um
i'm gonna go to the second round i'm
gonna pick one second rounder here
because i'm gonna pick jonathan taylor
the running back out of wisconsin
yes i thought he was the second best
running back in the draft
he's got great power he's almost 230
pounds and he was the fastest running
back in the draft at 439 at that time
that size is pretty special and why i
think that he'll have the most immediate
impact was because we know they got a
big blue wall
in indianapolis they got one of the best
o lines there is let alone is creative
and what they do on the offensive side
of the ball in the running game and
jonathan taylor to me is a home run
hitter a big time superstar talent and i
think when all said and done he will be
their bell cow main two main go-to
running back
and you know this gets back to something
we addressed in the aftermath of
christian mccaffrey getting his big
contract from the panthers not all that
long ago
these running backs who are in line for
a second contract
may not get one and marlon mack just saw
his chances of getting paid by the colts
disappear i think for good because right
they're going to let matt go and they're
going to keep jonathan taylor and
jonathan taylor's going to be the
cornerstone of the rushing attack after
this year one last thing before we break
because we mentioned both warren sapp
and chris jenkins in the same comparison
to derrick brown and they probably
didn't appreciate that because they
don't like each other i got a quote from
chris jenkins about warren sapp from
2005 one of the all-time great quotes
here's what jenkins had to say about
sapp i hate him
everybody says i'm supposed to be polite
when i talk to reporters but i hate him
he talks too much he doesn't make sense
he's fat he's sloppy he acts like he's
the best thing since sliced bread he's
ugly he stinks his mouth stinks his
breath stinks and basically his soul
stinks chris jenkins on warren sapp
chris
there was um some real bad blood in 2003
when i got to the tampa bay buccaneers
between the buccaneers and the carolina
panthers because the buccaneers defense
mike as we know with sapp and derek
brooks and john lynch and rondae barber
they were the kings of the nfc and the
kings of the nfc south but the panthers
with chris jenkins and
julius peppers
and everybody else that came along with
them uh brenton buckner and all those
guys they wanted to take the title away
they had enough of the tampa bay
buccaneers so there was some bad blood
stewing right as right as warren sapp
was leaving tampa bay and that continued
to when he went to the raiders chris
jenkins still made it be known that he
didn't like that guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports